today on our show it's just us watching
the Justice League trailer we're punny
today [ __ ] that man on that my mom Kim
I'm Marvin Arden hey Mark ya know that
they made a Justice League movie and
there's a trailer on the interwebs I've
heard tell of such things explain more
to me please
they released on the anniversary the
one-year anniversary of the release the
obstacle release of batman v superman
zack snyder gifted us with trailer for
the Justice League now we've seen a
Justice League trailer that came out of
this woman commander of Comic Con so any
comic-con then they release this is I
think the second trailer well they took
that one and they kind of sniffing they
kind of turn that into a first trail but
this is called the first official
trailer on maybe that was a teaser and
this is a trailer but we've seen footage
before of Justice League
Batman building the team but this is
more footage has a lot more every
characters represented and you get to
see how [ __ ] on a parody I love that
in there we live in a world apparently
where the release of Batman V Superman
is a date we are mocking in some way
like like you know May 1977 in Star Wars
comes out and then there will be
somebody gives a [ __ ]
I mean yesterday Arbor Day VBS Day a day
which were living in to me if it's
important apparently to Zack and you
know obviously it was you know talking
rights to to be like hey man one year
after that movie here's a [ __ ] should
look at the next movie I mean March used
to be special to him March was a big
year because that's when 300 was out in
March Sunday that's why our trailer
right he launched Martha and March March
Madness earlier he was in a very real
way the dude who established March as a
month you could open a movie in and
haven't make money that's true man he
dialed the summer back but you month you
did at the power of Zak's night Thank
You Zack Snyder yeah because now summer
begins in March Pacific Cinna calm they
showed up him and Bruce Wayne aka Ben
Affleck and Jason Momoa aka aqua
and Ezra Miller I think was very hey
flash and Ray Fischer's that his name
yes a cyborg the only aka wasn't there
was wonderful it's not right in
appearance I wasn't a [ __ ] torsed
ovary syndrome go somewhere at Walmart
I'm no Wonder Woman merchandise I'm
moving is like coming yeah coming hard I
mean I think they realized that you know
women is a huge market maybe I don't
know like women like movies I know I've
heard tell that they are fifty one
percent of the population and some of
that segment actually likes to go to
movies and even some of that segment
like superhero movies so and everybody
likes a good movie and then one of those
is yet so you know and then that segment
would buy pounds easy I'm trying to do
it fears hmm
Bob easy hey hey way to go thank you
trying until we get credit for here
America effort trophies forever here's
the idea at lady Jung who Justice League
trailer has dropped dropped a week ago
dropped last Saturday and stuff it's
it's it's it's it's a trailer it's good
dress it's a good trailer that is
unfortunately you know got it concerned
with the amazing spider-man trailer
which is amazing job but this trailer is
fantastic I've watched this trailer at
least 20 times since they released it
it's you know we get to see the building
of the universe you can see them trying
to course-correct
a little bit make it more fun and
inviting and stuff like that they're
still however a bit of a sense of and
none more black feel to it yeah it feels
like they're still be saturating the
movie you think I'm even taking some of
them bright colors and stuff and one
character suspiciously absent from that
trailer work
who said it didn't benefit oh that's not
music anymore now it's me they admitted
me Superman still no not an evidence
that has called some on the Internet to
speculate that he may be the villain
interesting even think of that
I did not think I did good I until I saw
that theory I mean because you do see
Lois Lane in this trailer and she's like
oh [ __ ] not hit him know in another one
and maybe she thought she was it was the
arrived have enough her she yeah that's
right she's in the trailer we have a lot
of slamming white could have a little
claim of that Superman but she's the key
that's what I believe we were told by
flash in Batman V Superman dat one
secret what why is she the key we're
gonna find out it's a man's got to be in
this movie and I think I wonder if like
when he comes back he's a dark side
soldier they got a fight it could be
because we haven't seen their big bad
we've seen a lot of parademons telling
trailers lots of parademons and in the
world of faceless villains like the
Chitauri or whatever the [ __ ]
giveme parademons i at least you know
they're parademons they're meant to be
faithful [ __ ] masses from apocalypse
right
Darkseid's [ __ ] and also at san diego
comic-con last year
henry cavill was there yeah so it's not
land henry cavill is about the cynic on
stage as well yeah
so then we hide in this [ __ ] in the
marketing um play think it's a good idea
maybe cuz every piece of footage of him
is in black suit and battling the
Justice League
what could either be a being a pure
electricity just speculate on blue I
lived through that become alright so
let's without further ado let's dive in
since I was a kid watching Super Friends
the dreams with a lot of action Justice
League movie or Super Friends but we
didn't call it just play back then which
is called Super Friends yeah cuz dreams
what one of those would look like and
now we we know we're getting and so I'm
happy because I wanted this he's happy
yeah so [ __ ] off okay here we go man
Zack Snyder's Justice League trailer we
pray the volumes up we press play now oh
my god looks like Game of Thrones the
ice ball Lou idiot who's this gun horse
gotta be Bruce Wayne must be we're in
the Han Solo Hoth gear got blue blockers
DC [ __ ]
oh that's Bruce Wayne alright
the others see it would never occur to
me to go shoot some place like a vistas
like that there is it's the Batman that
cyborgs dad at STAR Labs Myles Bennett
Dyson was Wonder Woman action or Diana
talking to Bruce Wayne yeah Ben's the
star of this show Jason Momoa as Aquaman
seeing some people complain about these
effects really off black toaster yeah an
ethical black so I'm in I like to shot
him throwing him in the sky look at that
flash look at them [ __ ] riding the
lightning I give it up for the flash
effect that looks [ __ ] astounding
reinforcing that best beautiful yeah him
running shoe look at this [ __ ] look at
all the green screen look at all the not
real this must have cost a couple
hundred bucks in the norm play that [ __ ]
Aquaman and Lansing with the [ __ ]
Trident to parademons like this I like
the inside board go Iron Man look at how
fast Barry Allen's movie I'm almost 20
strong you got a joke in the trailer
room we'll get a couple of other one
well Shona my trick
I'm sure Quinn apparently he's got a
vehicle at Wong's like the one in the
Batman Lego move look at that [ __ ]
lightning run man is Lois Lane Mira
[ __ ] Barry Allen set and Amazonians
battling somebody Batman [ __ ]
shooting the Batmobiles [ __ ] guns
which he shouldn't have their act
parademons and then oddly enough two
three heroes Commissioner Gordon just
like in the dig - all collected may be
temporary
yeah Aquaman riding on top of the
Batmobile is one of the most metal
things that you will see all year some
consent this is a very metal trailer I
know it ain't spider-man but I'm still
very excited for that that's a [ __ ]
balls out trailer you could tell they're
like look let's Shawn that we got the
goods or what they think of it good cuz
I guarantee you like last time they feel
like they had the goods yeah but never
like and they just said after after that
movie like clearly we misjudge the
marketplace we do know what the goods
were yeah and now we're gonna place the
goods we will identify the goods we gave
you bad and we're going to turn them
into good we're doing I would way that I
invoice correction I am here for water
polo Braille Aquaman yeah absolutely
yeah you know like that bond I don't
know how that jives with anything we've
ever seen a buckle man ever in the
history of Aquaman they've already taken
him away from the orange shirt so [ __ ]
yeah did you yeah you're cool you got a
call I'll ride it motorcycle awesome man
basically he's Lobo in the water wine in
fancy is water I think one of them
literally cast him as Lobos but thank
God that gives Aquaman because boy
that's light night who somebody once
told you years ago one of the best
characters or maybe the best character
in the Justice League trailer was gonna
be Optimus [ __ ] mind
he talked to fish [ __ ] he controls
how much how much the earth is ocean 75%
he lives under it so he keep his bodies
flying wrong cuz he could be crushed by
[ __ ] sighs I am finally Aquaman is gonna
have his [ __ ] dead water Drago who'd
I mean would not have thought would not
have thought that that would be the
thing
jaysus leaves Septimus it's there they
did it's comin justly he's coming man
you can't stop it and it happens when
November November you can't stop it no
matter how much you might want to you
man receive man what is the one is our
spider-man come July they on fourth of
July weekend and and so just way comes
out November so a couple months after I
get a space between I merely a little
space between you don't forget I'm a but
let me get a bit of Ragnarok in there
also where I think it's also November
[ __ ] hella I'm all for that
hello Valarie yeah and whole planet all
[ __ ] fine
where's my trailer Marvel yeah where's
that when's that come out that trailer
no when's that movie coming out because
the worst vitamin or not
Thor of indoors November yeah so Thor is
up against Justice League Marvel can to
drop [ __ ] DC has that weekend nope
had Jamie people of curly texture is
like I [ __ ] left it on the table I
put everything out there like yeah but
they got Hulk an armored tricky business
man I don't why I stay out of it because
I was just gonna do that nobody ever
asked there it is folks we have watched
the Justice League trailer and you've
watched us watching the Justice League
trailer and I'm not a letter grade God
but if I was given a letter grade I'd
give it a letter don't exist yet really
that's how good I look kind of like
Greek symbol for things yeah I can I
create something go to a graphic artist
have lousy with and paying hundred bucks
they come up with a symbol kind of like
what Lex Luthor did in Batman V Superman
nothing but we make everybody who stands
for one year.you and I got to go total
[ __ ] classic that would be good
nameless
that's when you know you've had free
time yeah we don't make a lift
um there it is if I had a glyph to
represent how I feel about this just
like jello did this make that caliph
young art student young hungry art here
but is that what like emojis are
basically
Mega Man um oh yeah I guess he was the
original emoji well the original emoji
was whoever came up with a smiling happy
face goof our Gump in the movie no you
sure I don't know I'm pretty sure that
that's a text bond with that person I'd
be like what the [ __ ] man if everything
else was a variation of the smile face
you know I'm just saying like there's a
direct line from Forrest Gump to Donald
Trump and stomp the Trump Gump to trump
mark barnard new book hitting people
crunk up to trump how we lost America
cornered he ain't doing acne working on
that Castlerock ship yeah don't you let
him [ __ ] fool you I'm just joshing
I'm not writing books about Trump like
too short
he's writing about Stephen King kill
yeah well you can't say anything I can
say but it's going really well like that
there you go
yes there's a print that we're riding on
off of website it's going well says
writer on show that's rock bottom there
it is folks we're done watching this
[ __ ] go back to your day and stuff
we'll watch something else when it
happens that's what we do here we're
dirty little cups we like to watch for
Batman I'm Batman Kevin sir I am NOT a
dirty little cocky mama didn't raise no
cut well mine did I'll come back next
episode and hang out the same Chuck time
same cuff channel mark f comma warf
YouTube that slams last dirty little cup
[Music]
you
[Music]